non non je crois que ce rapport est
assez exhaustif il montre un état
préoccupant des forces de police et moi
je veux rendre hommage aux deux
policiers qui ont été roués de coups il
ya malheureusement quelques quelques
heures quelques jours je crois qu'on
vient de l'arrestation d'un des
agresseurs il faut que la justice
maintenant sévices on voit bien que il
n'y a plus d'interdît
on va chercher les policiers chez eux
pour se venger de ce qu'ils ont pu faire
ils sont face au terrorisme se souvient
de l'assassinât de ses deux policiers à
magnanville ils sont totalement exposés
personnellement on voit les problèmes
sociaux où il faut faire face
j'allais dire aux cortèges aux
difficultés sociales il ya les problèmes
migratoires qui mobilise beaucoup de
policiers également aux frontières et à
tous les problèmes d'ordre public
tout ça fait qu'il ya une exaspération
pas ce qu'on leur demande beaucoup et on
n'a pas parlé dans ce rapport
malheureusement de quelque chose qui
fait sujet également dans les hôpitaux
c'est les 35 heures le statut horaires
des policiers fait qu' il faut beaucoup
de policiers et que même si il en manque
il faut embaucher des efforts ont été
faits sur le plan budgétaire il faut les
former avant qu'ils arrivent sur sur le
terrain il ya un vrai malaise 22
millions on vient de lire 22 millions
d'heures supplémentaires non payées
pasta vrai c'est un vrai problème ils
sont fatigués sont exaspérés et quand la
police d'un pays est dans cet état c'est
préoccupant parce que la police c'est ce
qui permet de maintenir l'ordre dans la
société d'être un rempart face aux
dérives et on a besoin d'avoir une
police qui soit solide
on a vu à notre dame des landes les
forces de l'ordre exposé dangereusement
face à des manifestants armés parfois
hier à nantes
on a vu encore les débordements un
policier a pris une balle de 22 long
rifle dans son casque enfin on est
maintenant à un niveau de dangerosité
pour la police qui est extrêmement
préoccupant alors on en revient